let's move forward goodness that time
goes fast I promised that I was going to
give you an example where I didn't do
the drawing for you because that is a
lot of the legwork and a lot of you guys
but the graphing is the part that you
struggle with so this time I'm going to
give you a good few minutes to have a go
at this and then what I'd like you to do
is for Part A you can see it's just kind
of like it's a scaffold is what we
teachers call it so I'm kind of gently
kind of guiding you into the question
part a will help you with Part B I'm
gonna let you work out how exactly Part
B it says find the area so this is the
the classic kind of question we've been
looking at so far what I'd like you to
do is go through Part A do that and then
in Part B give us a thumbs up once you
have completed the sketch um you don't
have to have completed the answer but
once you have a sketch even if it's
wrong that's okay I'm gonna step in at
that point where enough of you are at
that point and show you what the graph
is supposed to look like just in case
some of you are on the wrong track and I
can help you out so Part A you're um
you're being given two graphs and you're
going to find a point of intersection
I'm kind of giving you a hand there to
work it out and then in Part B go
through the same yes I see that we've
been talking about for sketch identify
those integrals and then thank you mrs.
Lee's and then have a go at doing the
combination and conclusion so give us a
thumbs up or go ahead and say yes on the
form actually when you've gone past just
Part A I actually would love you to have
a sketch as well because I know that
part's gonna take some time so have a go
I don't know if you can edit forms can
you edit forms mrs. Lee's I'll give you
guys a few minutes to do that thank you
that's amazing all right so off you go
come back together in a few okay so just
just judging on where everyone is voting
on the forms if you have accurately
reported there's a number of you who
have got Part A which is great I'm
showing you my working for Part A here
because I don't want you to get too hung
up on it I will admit it's not the kind
of question that you normally get given
so you might look at it and think I'm
not I think I can do this but I'm not
sure how to approach it since I'm going
to show you this working here
to be honest it's actually just a way to
help you out in Part B in working out
the x value that's going to be relevant
to us you know as you saw in the first
example we did today you need a point of
intersection so here is one which is
very similar to that we're going to need
a point of intersection and Part A was
just kind of an underhanded way to help
you out if you have not done with Part A
I want you to move forward and start
having a go at Part B and you can use my
working for Part A which I'll leave on
the screen for a little bit have a go at
thinking about what these two curves
look like and how they interact with
each other especially when you know this
extra piece of information that I've
just provided to you about where they
both passed through so when as you can
see a graph gets given to you that takes
a lot of a leg work out of the
understanding of the question and
frequently we will do that because we're
nice but often you really do have to do
the work particularly as you get further
and further into the course by the end
of this you know entire thing you're
going to be able to know all of the
things that you've been taught in this
course and so we're gonna expect you to
combine them in all kinds of different
ways so this is us calling on your
knowledge of you know parabolas of
sketching all different kinds of
functions your coordinate geometry to
combine that and then the integration
comes in to sort of tie that all up in a
neat bow so I'll give you a few more
minutes
had to have a go at that and I'm looking
for some people to say yes we've got a
graph or otherwise to say I'm completely
out at sea I don't know what to do here
please help me please rescue me from
this okay
so I'll leave my working for Part A
there and then we are we're gonna move
on shortly all right so it's starting to
break down like 50-50 between the yeses
and the nose so I am a time and I think
I'm gonna have a go at showing you what
this thing is going to look like okay
now what I'll do is I'm just going to
copy down this part of the question so
that you can see it when I scroll so the
particularly important things that we're
looking for this curve here and let's
choose green shall we this curve over
here all right so these are the ones
we're going to focus on no
for starters you've got y equals 1 minus
X cubed now what's that going to look
like well if I draw myself a very rough
set a corner axes here okay there we go
I'm going to draw it in red so you can
tell that that's the cubic curve that
were interested in there are firstly the
things to start with is that it's a
cubic curve so I know roughly speaking
you don't draw this this is the rough
shape of a cubic curve that's not very
beautiful but you get the idea I'm you
can see that there's also a minus sign
at the front of the execute so it's
actually going to go around the other
way it's going to be decreasing rather
increasing and if this is unfamiliar to
you then relax next week we're going to
go into further work on graphing and if
this is unfamiliar with you we will work
back on that and then lastly you can see
this is one at the front which has the
effect of raising it up one unit okay so
I'm going to be graphing something like
this raised up one there's the first
thing the second thing is let's have a
go at this guy over here now I want to
do some simplification of this so I'm
going to take out a factor of two which
is what Max was alluding to before this
is what I get from the factorization of
two and then I'm going to factorize
further by noticing that this is a
quadratic it's actually a perfect square
so I can write this as X plus 2 all
squared ok so now let's have a go at
trying to plot this on here I'm going to
put negative 1 negative 2 because I can
see I've got an x intercept of negative
2 and then I'm going to very roughly
again this is just for the purposes of
illustration so it doesn't have to be
beautiful I'm gonna roughly draw my
parabola here there we go
like I said not beautiful but it does
the job for me
okay now what do I know about this
parabola well I know there's an x
intercept there and I also know a
y-intercept you can find that out if you
put in x equals 0 to my green graph okay
now with my red I'm going to piece
together the other piece right so this
is the cubic graph so I noticed that
from this point up here again there's a
y-intercept of 1 so let me get a rough
scale here there's a 4 that's gonna be
1/2 - there's one so I'm gonna put that
intercepts right there I also know that
I've got a point of intersection from
hey do you remember that I have a point
of intersection at negative one comma
two so that's going to be here okay it's
a bit fat you get the idea actually no
it's a bit lower sorry about that it's
gonna be more like there that's better
okay so I'm going to thread together
these parts of the graph like sir mmm
yeah I'm happy with that that'll do me
okay so I've got now the two graphs
together and I've been asked to find the
area that's bounded between the red
graph the green graph and the x-axis so
you can see the relevant part in here
I'm going to draw across the bottom so I
hope you can see let me put in maybe
yellow underneath there okay this shaded
area this little thin section this is
the area that I'm interested in
okay so sketch is done how can I
identify the appropriate integrals well
I need some X values right I can see
that there's going to be the part that's
underneath the green graph and the part
that's underneath the red graph so let's
have a look over here on the left-hand
side this portion here which I'm
highlighting in green is entirely
underneath the parabola I know it starts
at negative two can anyone tell me where
the value is for negative one oh sorry
Mary your question about one that's
actually that's a bit sneaky the the one
that I've drawn in here is actually that
point right there it's just that I've
kind of run out of space to put it I
apologize for that it's really referring
to that cross where it goes through the
axis so that's a 1 and this point above
right here that's a 2 so that's why you
can see this is negative 1 comma 2 which
is kind of me answering my own question
so I've got an x value there where I'm
going to stop looking underneath the the
green graph that's negative 1 okay so
here's my first part and if you want you
could name this as a 1 for area 1 it's
going to be an integral underneath the
parabola from negative 2 to negative 1
and then I've got this other section
right on the right-hand side you can see
the cubic takes over
this section I'm now highlighting in red
has nothing to do with the parabola in
fact I can just show you and delete the
parabola out of there you can see the
red region is sitting entirely
underneath the cubic curve so I'll put
the problem back because I do want it so
I need to integrate on one minus x cubed
I know my start point is negative one
but I don't know my end point over here
what's that going to be how do I find
this x-intercept think back to how we
did this before how do I find the
x-intercept to get that red value any
takers
okay fantastic yeah y equals zero into
the queue well done
Jana for being first in so my cubic
after all is and I should have labeled
this on the graph which was a bit cheeky
of me
it's 1 minus X cubed so when I go ahead
and solve for y equals 0 I'm going to
get let's put it underneath here 1 minus
X cubed equals 0 I'm going to add X
cubed to both sides
excuse me that and there's only a single
value that does that which is x equals 1
so that's what gives me this value in
here so now I've got a start and end for
this second area in here which I'll call
a 2 so I'm ready to go I have sketched
that took some time I have identified
the integrals now all that's left is to
actually write them so let me put this
aside so I have a little bit of space
over here this was how I worked out that
value so a 1 is going to be equal to the
integral from negative 2 to negative 1
underneath the parabola which I think we
said was 2 x squared plus 8x plus 8 with
respect to X and then I'm going to get a
2 which is the integral takes over from
negative 1 and carries all the way
through to positive 1
so negative 1 to 1 of 1 minus X cubed DX
okay